do you think that
women not having families has
contributed to their unhappiness as we
see less and less families i think
majority yeah majority of women
i would say yes as well i just think
getting to that age of 30 um i don't
know i'm reaching that soon i mean i'm
in a relationship and i hear it all the
time like i'm already hearing why you're
not married yet why don't you have kids
yet what's going on la la la that that i
hate them questions but you get it all
the time so i imagine women being over
30 they'll probably get that as well
from family members friends co-workers
whatever yeah
oh yeah yeah
um
i think we
well we all know that in terms of
we a lot of women are now one of they're
chasing the i'm a single independent
strong woman etc
um and a consequence of that is the
women in their i think it's over 40 um
and successful for women 45 successful
queer women over 45
um are unhappy as a consequence of it um
so
really in the context of this women need
more well we need to rethink what it is
that um they're looking to achieve
because
if the narrative is being pushed that
you know be chase your career but in the
consequence of that as you ended up on
antidepressants clearly something's not
working in in in society um meg james
talks about it in in the book the
defining decade
where a lot of people seem to rethink
seem to think that thirty is a new
twenty so a lot of people pushed a lot
their responsibilities in their twenties
into the thirties and later ages to
chase careers to chase whatever it is
that um they think is beneficial for
their well-being and then it turns out
that when they get to the age of 30 and
upwards and they haven't achieved
certain things that's when the
depression starts to take place so again
we do need to do a rethinking of
what what is the most important thing
and the numbers do say that for most
people it is marriage and a family yet
that's not the narrative being pushed in
in
um in in news media or social media um a
lot of our role models who in a lot of
cases are in relationships we'll be
actively telling women don't don't
pursue these things so i think yeah
there's definitely a problem sorry
um the premise of that do we really
think that um
do we really think that
men also want families and children yes
yeah we do yeah
okay because again once again my ex
didn't want children
vehemently against having them didn't
like them
i
and this was the guy who i would have
spent the rest of my life with by the
way because obviously i can't have
children i don't plan to do anything
about that maybe if i'm 14 i decide you
could adopt you know i and i've thought
about that but i certainly don't want to
do it now
you know what i
i would do the same thing i didn't with
my
ex-boyfriend and not be bringing up that
child in a in in the best environment i
don't know and i'm just not going to do
that and i think that's a bit a massive
issue
with
modern relationships and and children
it's the single-parent homes
well i don't think necessarily just
single parent okay but but certainly
that's an issue right but i also just
think
um people who aren't ready for kids just
in general right
um because
i mean again this does
like i'm not you know i never said that
i disagreed with the whole premise that
you know relationships are good or some
sort of partnership with someone is good
and when that partnership is good it's
better for the children i totally
totally support that you know i'm not
saying that anyone should be in a
single-parent household but um
but certainly you know when when
you know
i think there's a there's a stage isn't
there i would imagine it as someone who
can't and hasn't ever had that pool to
have a baby or pull to her whatever i
imagine that for other people there's a
stage in their young lives where
sometimes they think oh
stupidly or wouldn't it be great if we
had a baby
i don't know i just feel like that
happens i've certainly heard
you know how
when you're younger because obviously
your decision-making yeah your
biological clock yes yes but is it just
biological or is it just young decision
making
well because they say that something
about your decision well you're the most
you're the most fertile when you're like
i think 21 22. yeah so that's when
you're probably when they're all over
the hormones are all over the place i
wanted a kid i i really really wonder
kid and i'd be the first to say i had a
child at 19. that's very very very young
like i think
it it just depends on a person like i
really really wanted a baby i was in a
relationship i was in love first time
i'd ever been in love you know i didn't
come from a household where i was told
that i loved it my mum loved me like i
said the family unit wasn't you know
fantastic so for me having a baby was
this is someone that can love me and
someone that i will love
i learned very quickly that i don't need
to have a baby i've got a job i've got a
boyfriend get on fit then i felt
pregnant so for me it was like okay now
i have this baby
still in love with her dad things happen
we fell out but i think it's important
to not put everybody in the category of
being in a single parent home like i am
obviously just meeting my daughter in
the house however
her dad is very much involved so i'm not
a single parent i do not see myself as a
single parent and i think there's a lot
of families out there where the dad is
involved and people class
single person they're not well i mean
they you might not say that they're
single parent but like statistically
they still are and you still put your
kid at every statistical disadvantage
when you take the dad out of the home
even if he's involved
to a degree
yeah if they don't have the involvement
from their father because i know plenty
of children that don't but my daughter
has a very good relationship with her
and i believe that there's probably a
lot more parents that do that don't get
the right mission do you think she would
have preferred that you guys not be
together or preferred to have both of
you in the house oh no gosh you
definitely preferred her together she's
very vocal about that yeah she's
extremely vocal about it and so like
it's kind of wouldn't it be better
advice to younger women to
maybe not point out the exception but
maybe point out the rule
yeah no i agree i mean i don't i bring
her up like how i said now i view it
like i should have worked on things i
should have watched you know what you
mean and she knows that we've spoken
about it she's a big girl she's 17 like
we've had is he still single
no he's not he's married oh okay i was
like maybe you could call him and work
it out
he's happily married
like do you tell your to you tell your
daughter um
to seek out these certain situations
with a man like do you tell her
how old is she she's 17. i don't tell
her to actually go and do it now right
now she's focusing on school and of
course of course obviously but when
you're telling me about men do you talk
about the nuclear family in in that
regard do you because what i find is
that um it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
like a lot of women will will have the
breakdown of the home blame the man
and then impart that same knowledge on
their daughter so the daughter grows up
thinking she wants a stable family but
you know based on the situation or she's
learnt from my mom she doesn't really
care too much about that and then that
same situation occurs in
no i i don't feel personally like i've
laid that into her i feel like i have
broke it down like it i was just as much
to blame as he was
like even though things broke down
because of certain issues
like i also had a part to play in it
it's never just one-sided okay
okay i'm gonna read super chats real
quick guys
how many people are in the chat right
now we got 2 300. guys like the video i
i don't think we had a thousand likes on
the video hit that like button a like is
free guys also if you want to be
involved in our in the chat the second
half of the show sign up for our
memberships we just turned on members
only on top of that subscribe to the
channel come on guys a subscribe is free
so i'm gonna read the super chat so zhv
two thousand three hundred